our commencement coverage continues on
c-span with a speech from sidney poitier
this year the actor received a lifetime
achievement academy award for both his
film work and humanitarian efforts
in may he spoke to the graduates of
claremont mckenna college in california
good afternoon all
here at the outset i am pressed
by conscience to admit
that when i first received your most
generous invitation to come and speak i
was troubled by the thought of what
could i possibly
have of interest to say
to an educated well-rounded awesomely
cool audience like you
i've not been to my satisfaction fully
able to put that thought to rest
in fact while waiting to be introduced a
few minutes ago the grounds for my
earlier concern
intensified as it gradually became
clear that your presence here indeed
speaks of quick minds
keen interest vibrant curiosities and
expectations that threaten to keep me on
my toes and make me reach beyond my
grasp
all of which give rise to more than a
little nervousness
because if you are in fact all those
things quick and curious and expectant
it means i will have to struggle to
measure up
so that you won't have to measure down
i would hate that
talking to people that much smarter than
me is first
risky
because my ignorance will have no place
to hide from your
computer fast minds
listening for
philosophical truths
historical gems political insights
spiritual resonances
and errors of grammar
errors of grammar
are about all you are likely to get
second
it flies in the face of logic because
class of 2002
you at your present level of knowledge
know at least 50 times more than i knew
when i was at your present level of age
so
what could i say
what should i say
well i've decided whatever i say i will
speak it only to you
parents faculty and friends can listen
if they want but my remarks
will be from me directly to you class of
2002
pride
in this institution's long and honored
tradition of nurturing the development
and growth of civilized society
is never more exemplified than on days
like this
when the labor of teachers and students
faculty and parents
is harvested
and made ready to lend itself to the
process of continuance
to the widening deepening and extending
of both civilized society and the
opportunities this university believes
will be waiting for you
the class of 2002.
in each of the generations of graduates
who have gone before you
there were those who came with visions
so unique as to set new standards in
their time
no need in these brief remarks to
identify them by name or profession or
by contribution
since their bodies of work have been
preserved
and stand in witness to their history
fact by fact
it is therefore undeniable that
your ambition and mine were stirred and
shaped
by impressions left on each of us by the
power of their gifts
today class of 2002 if by chance you
feel obliged
by your creative passion
to reach beyond them
to raise the level of the bar yet
another notch in your time through your
life's work let me tell you
that's a good sign
class of 2002 if restless expectations
are thrashing about inside you in
anticipation of what the future holds
that's a good sign
if you are
already searching and listening
for hints as to when
and where you might cross paths with
that defining moment that window of
opportunity through which you
and your education and talent will burst
upon the world maybe tomorrow
maybe next week maybe next month
that's a good sign
class of 2002
you are poised at the edge of new
beginnings your journey ready to take
wings
precisely as the clouds of my journeys
end are gathering up ahead
because
the time has come when the aged and
weakened wings of my generation's
journey can no longer hold their own
against the wind
if you see that
as fact and that fact as one of life's
unending processes
that's a good sign
class of 2002 this is the day
the decks are cleared
this is the day you position yourselves
for what tomorrow brings
there can be no better time than now
filled as you are with the satisfaction
that always comes after a giant step has
been taken
no better moment to take one last look
back
across the many books you've cracked
the many hours you've logged the many
lessons you've learned
the many lectures you've internalized
the many facts you've unearthed
the many tiny bits of knowledge that you
have captured and have captured your
imagination
i advise you to look closely
and if you spot genuine moments of
clarity flashes of insight and pearls of
wisdom
that's a good sign
make note of them and
chances are they will return to warm
your heart at 75
now be forewarned and not misled by what
you've heard me say
i've not come to stroke you
i've come
to challenge you
and if i am successful
you will recognize glimpses of
yourselves somewhere in the remarks to
follow
none of which is gospel most of which
even i have somehow managed to survive
but not without the hands of unseen
forces being somewhere in the details
however
since serendipity
providence
luck
karma
and other such intangibles can never be
directed by our hands
and must forever lie outside of our
control
you
must yourselves
be responsible for setting the goals
choosing the route and staying the
course
only you can articulate the distance you
are willing to travel to become the you
you want to be
at 75
and me the me i'd like to be
at a hundred and three
if you agree
that for each of us
our journeys distance from where we are
to where we want to be
can best be measured by the size of our
will
and the passion of our intent
that's a good sign
i now invite you to join me
in an objective look at the moment at
hand
if you see the fact of my standing here
and you sitting there
as being pregnant with implications
imageries
obligations
possibilities and promise
that's a good sign
there are differences between us
you and i
certainly
more than meet the eye
there is a space between us
a distance
a divide
after all i am 75 and you are in your
golden twenties and thirties
which obliges me
to suggest
you be ever mindful of the fact that
life is tough
damn
right
especially for those of us who tend to
sit or stand on one of life's corners
too long
however hard we look we will never see
as far as we should
however long we watch we will seldom
comprehend as clearly as we could
however much talk we hear of wonder we
will seldom
experience her touch
the narrowest view life will ever offer
of itself
is reserved for those of us who never
venture forth
who never travel those unknown roads
life knows who we are she also knows
where we are
but she really comes looking for those
of us who are at the heart of ourselves
spectators
her engines are not fired by us
she instead waits anxiously for the
coming of the curious traveler
to whom she offers no guarantee that one
road will lead to another
no promise that we won't get lost as
surely we will from time to time
no promise that we won't find ourselves
abandoned where disaster of some
unimaginable kind waits
and there be left to stand our ground
with only instinct for guidance and
trial and error for judgment
left to perish or prosper alone deserted
life is tough damn right
she knows curiosity sharpens instinct
instinct invites trial and error
trial and error produces experiences
and experiences are the only armor the
only protection she provides for those
travelers who will spend their days
on beckoning unknown roads that pull at
their curiosity
if you feel you can summon the resolve
necessary
to stand firm in face of all life's
challenges
with no guarantees that's a good sign
class of 2002
on the reasonable chance
that there may be those among you who
might well be wondering who is this 75
year old sidney poitier guy from a time
we never knew
well in
in the time you never knew
i earned my living these past years
as an actor director writer in theater
and films
i'm approaching the glow of a distant
sunset
accompanied by the shadow of my
accumulated ears
in which a reasonable number of unknown
roads have pulled at such curiosity as i
have had
i've come to see where you are and to
tell you where i've been and what i've
seen
in case
your journey takes you
over ground i've covered
and it too can be said i've come to
learn what you can teach me
when we are done with each other this
day i hope it will have been for good
and sound reasons that we came together
at this particular point in our lives
coming as we have
from different times
from
different places
on different journeys in different
directions
while we each you and i have arrived at
this moment burdened with the
complexities of generational differences
i sincerely hope that we discover a
small patch of common ground on which we
may stand and share in this short time
we have as we pass each other by
my generation heading towards its final
years
and your generation towards the arena
where the game of life is played
whomever you are however old you are
20 years old at the threshold
seasoned traveler deep in the journey or
the curious traveler seeking out
along some unknown road the mysteries
hidden in himself
know that i come
with the weight of such accumulated
accumulations as my spent years have
left me
experiences
burdens
victories
flaws
failures inadequacies disappointments
accomplishments obligations regrets
success mistakes and worst of all
a heart
that has been broken
more than a few times
yes
as you can clearly see the shadows of my
deeds are etched upon my face
along with the other requisite scars of
survival
indeed i stand as proof positive that
the wear and tear on the body the mind
the spirit and the soul is inescapable
after such a long time in the arena of
life
no matter what you're thinking trust me
you are not going to look any better
than us when
[Applause]
when
when time
one day
finally delivers you
where we once stood facing as you must
the distant sunset of your own years
this is how one comes to be as one's
journey winds down
if you have had
glimpses of yourselves in the foregoing
scenario that's a good sign
in a time you never knew
standards were set
planted deep in the discipline you have
chosen
where
roots took hold and left markers of
excellence
and now
as your journey began they're waiting to
test your measure
to see your stuff
observe your style
looking to see how well you do at
keeping instinct and intuition out of
the abusive reach of convenience
as you come with decades yet and spent
with which to deal
challenges you haven't dreamed of are
waiting for you if you feel
that it is in your nature to rise to
each of them
show them your stuff
and declare that driven by will and
intent you've come to leave your mark
plant your vision
and set new standards
if that be the ground you intend to
cover over the distance of your journey
let me tell you class of 2002
that's one hell of a good sign
good luck
and godspeed
[Applause]
alberto gonzalez was the speaker at
catholic university's law school
graduation
the white house council spoke for 20
minutes at the school's 130th annual
commencement ceremony
his may 25th speech runs 20 minutes